the Saturn 5 rocket that lifted the
Apollo 11 spacecraft out of Earth's
orbit had been reduced to its final
stage the s4 be a command and service
module or CSM separated from the s4 be
turned through 180 degrees and docked
with the lunar module or LEM the now
combined CSM and LEM pulled away from
the s4 be rocket proceeding on it's
roughly 250,000 mile journey to the moon
during the translunar Coast phase almost
three days later the spacecraft entered
lunar orbit the crew spent the next 25
hours performing various systems checks
and tests while in orbit around the moon
in preparation for landing Neil
Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin transferred to
the LEM by Michael Collins remained in
the CSM at CSM undocked and separated
from the LEM now functioning as two
separate vehicles the CSM was
re-designated Columbia and the LEM Eagle
Eagles decent orbit initiation began
[Music]
followed by the power to descent
initiation after 102 hours and 45
minutes of traveling through space Eagle
became the first manned spacecraft to
land on the moon once safely on the
lunar surface Armstrong and Aldrin
performed a check out of all systems and
prepared for their historic moonwalk 109
hours and 42 minutes after launch Neil
Armstrong became the first human to set
foot on the lunar surface and delivered
his famous words Aldrin joined Armstrong
on the lunar surface shortly after and
the pair collected lunar surface samples
and conducted experiments they stayed on
the moon for just under one day eagle
ascended from the lunar surface to
rendezvous and dock with Columbia which
had been orbiting the moon during the
lunar landing Columbia docked with eagle
and Armstrong and Aldrin reunited with
Collins in the CSM the LEM ascent stage
was jettisoned and the CSM entered the
trans earth injection phase to make the
voyage back to earth
[Music]
the service section of the CSM was
ejected before entering Earth's
atmosphere
finally 195 hours 18 minutes and 35
seconds after departing the earth the
command module splashdown in the Pacific
Ocean of the 24th of July after
traveling a total distance of over
800,000 nautical miles
[Music]